in the wake of George Floyd's death the
black lives matter movement is
highlighting police unions and the role
they play in protecting officers Union
contracts can offer a range of
protections in Louisville Kentucky for
example the union contract requires that
officers involved in Brianna Taylor
shooting death received a 48-hour notice
before they were interrogated we've
reached out to that Union and have not
heard back
Errol Barnett though shows us how
contracts like these can affect
investigations into officers I am
immediately withdrawing from the
contract negotiations with the
Minneapolis Police Federation this
announcement may days after George
Floyd's killing exposed the complicated
relationships often existing between
police unions and local officials we are
sick and tired of the Police Federation
getting in the way in cities and towns
across the country lawmakers work with
police unions to negotiate officers
compensation and disciplinary procedures
those vary contracts determined at the
local level varying from city to city
and now a focal point of police reform
what these agreements often do is they
impede reasonable accountability efforts
and they often can service barriers to
reasonable investigation oversight and
disciplinary procedures Stephen Russian
teaches law at Loyola University in
Chicago where he also studies police
accountability take an example like San
Antonio Texas you got to give officers
before the interrogation access to video
evidence access to GPS coordinates
complaints witness statements and
affidavits before you can even question
them about allegations of misconduct
according to the San Antonio Police
Officers Association these provisions
apply only to alleged civil service rule
violations and have no bearing on any
criminal investigations officers may
face in a statement to CBS News the
Association said they're not quote
tone-deaf to the concerns of police
transparency going on to say their
collective bargaining agreement is a
living document adding as we move
forward in time and our industry adapts
to changes there will be a need to make
modifications Omaha Nebraska
like San Antonio allows officers to
review video evidence before they're
interrogated access to the video is only
there to help refresh the officers
memory so their officer is given the
most accurate statement to the incident
in Nebraska officer misconduct records
are confidential
Anthony Connor is president of the Omaha
Police Officers Association is it
possible for people in Omaha to see the
disciplinary records of police officers
similar to other public sector employees
no it's not do you think it should be to
gain the public's trust actually no I
don't want to try to situation but
whether it's George Floyd or the
incident Alanna you hear the argument
that the person's history doesn't matter
well if the history don't matter with
them why would it matter what a police
sauce yes that's where I think there's
some confusion and what the public says
they want well I guess the difference
would be one person is being paid to
protect people and the other is just a
citizen presumed innocent I can
recognize that but at the same time I
still think that personnel records
should not be open but kana does support
president Trump's recent executive order
calling for a database to track officers
excessive use of force you should not
have police officers that are fired from
one agency for misconduct and then hire
Galman down the road how does it feel to
hear the criticisms of unions in this
larger discussion of implementing
reforms it's kicking us out of the room
and not having us as part of the
conversation does the public have any
input in these police union contracts
yes they do because the public votes for
the mayor who's actually going to sign
the contract they vote for a city
council who votes for the contract where
a police department doesn't have the
resources to meet the financial demands
of the police unions an easy way to
settle that negotiation is to make some
concessions on discipline it's easy to
just blame the union but that doesn't
really get at the problem these
contracts didn't write themselves so the
question that is why are our political
leaders signing off on these bad deals
all across the country as negotiations
continue during Cole's for police reform
hole
local officials accountable Russian says
is essential the CBS this morning
Errol Barnett New York sounds like he's
right there this all comes down to
politics
alright Errol thank you very much